[Music]
hello everyone
my name is monica jones i'm a tv
journalist in berlin and i'm now going
to talk to
a scientist in brussels her name is
professor francois
mackler she's director of research with
fnrs at the university of liege
i'm going to tell you a little bit more
about her she's also a world leading
scientist in application
of quantum mechanics to the behavior of
mata she directs international teams of
researchers towards the development of
novel quantum technologies her work has
been recognized by both
european and american awards and here he
comes she's also
a renowned teacher and she's presented
classes on quantum technologies at both
belgian european
and israeli universities and that's
going to be
very very helpful for this talk now
because the talk is on quantum
technologies
reality or imagination a role for space
tricky talk no doubt and i'm very happy
to welcome now professor
remarkal good to have you with us uh and
please
have mercy on me let's agree first of
all that there is no
such thing as a stupid question and i'm
sure that everybody who is watching it
just like myself we've
heard about quantum physics but we don't
really have a clue what it's all about
or why we should care for that matter
but i'm sure we'll care about it after
we've spoken to you so so let's get
started first of all i mean we've all
heard about
classical physics that's what we learned
at school
how does quantum physics differ from it
it's a question of scale classical
mechanics governs the motion of planet
quantum mechanics governs the property
of matter at the atomic scale
and these scales are very very small
scales
of length of time and of masses
and the important point is that at these
scales
the discreteness of matter has important
measurable consequences and by
discreteness i mean
that matter is made of atom
and light is made of sub entities that
are called photon and the fact
that mata has a discrete character and
is made of
atom was already postulated by
a greek philosopher called democritus
almost 2500 years ago and atom
means in greek that cannot be cut so it
is really the
entities or the sub-entities of which
matter is made but speculation becomes
science
only when we can probe them and
verify them experimentally and it is
only at the turn
of the 20th century so a century ago
essentially that it became
possible to probe the quantum discrete
nature of matter and of energy
so as i already said atomic theory was
present throughout the development of
physics and chemistry
that light can be made of corpuscle
was already put forward by rene
descartes
and izzak newton in the 17th century but
in the years and in the centuries that
follows
it is another theory of light a
continuous
theory that light is made of waves
that become dominant and that was able
to explain
all the experiments that were that it
was possible to make at the time
but at the turn of the 20th century
there were
new experimental capabilities
that could not be explained that were
that made measurement that could not be
explained by a classical
theory and a famous one is known as the
uv catastrophe and to solve the problem
first max planck in 1901 and then albert
einstein in 1905 proposed the concept of
a quantum
of light that they called the photon at
the same time
it was also shown experimentally
that the energy in atom is discrete
and it was proved by measuring
discrete peaks in emission atomic
spectra
and these experiments and others
led to the development of quantum
mechanics and quantum mechanics was
established very quickly by
the late 1920s it was a complete theory
that was able to explain
all the experimental results that were
available at the time
and up to now all the prediction of
quantum mechanics
have been verified experimentally
it's quite amazing when you say that
it's been around
for so many decades and it still is an
enigma
to most of us but i should imagine
that that is also the reason why it is
so fascinating
it's incomprehensible to most people but
at the same time fascinating
i i think that the incomprehension that
is
generated by quantum mechanics has to do
with the fact
that quantum mechanics uses a logic
that is at variance with our day-to-day
life
one of the most important example
important because it has important
consequences in quantum mechanics and
important because it makes it very weird
is this property of delocalization
according to the law of quantum
mechanics i can be
here discussing with you and at the same
time in my office in liege
another very weird aspect is that
of the schrondy gaquette which is a
famous
thought experiment that is discussed a
lot
in quantum physics and there the weird
aspect is that
the cat can be simultaneously alive
and dead which is not something that we
experiment in our day-to-day life
and so all these properties are
extremely weird
but they stood the test of time even
though
very many scientists and very famous
scientists like einstein
strongly objected to them one of the
most important properties in quantum
mechanics is that
the as much as light
that is made of photon can
then behave like a particle at the
atomic scale like
electron or atoms can also behave
as waves and this is known as the
wave particle duality
and this is a concept that was
formalized by
a very young french scientist who was
also an aristocrat he was called louis
de bruyne
and he put forward this
concept in his stasis in 1924
this idea was so much novel
that it took the support of albert
einstein for his thesis to be
accepted what the the braille
relation states is that to
every atom or
electron one can associate
a wave whose wavelength is given
by the inverse of the product of
its mass times its velocity
the wavelength is eventually
proportional to the mass
and the velocity of the particle and if
you think of
the very very small masses of electron
and atoms
one then obtains a wavelength that is
large enough it is very small but it is
large enough that it is possible to
measure
the consequences of this particle having
also a wave that is associated to them
and then one can measure diffraction
patterns for example
of course because our masses mine
yours are so much bigger it means that
the wavelengths will be even smaller
and much much more smaller than the
wavelength that is associated
with atomic scale particle and for this
reason
one cannot measure the consequences of
the wave
character that is associated to
macroscopic object and so
the the discreteness of energy and also
the fact that
at the atomic scale we have direct
manifestation of the wave character
of particles so the consequences of this
wave particle duality
were exploited very early after the
development
of quantum mechanics and became
technologies and one of very famous
of the very famous example the laser
that is
present nowadays in a lot
of aspects of our life the laser i use
in cd players in remote control
another example are the transistors that
are in our computer in our phones and
even now in our fridge
all these examples of technologies are
direct consequences of these weird
properties of
quantum mechanics i have to check my
fridge because i was trying to
it's amazing i've been trying to follow
you and uh
here and then you lost me uh but uh
i think you did a perfect richard
feynman then of obviously a famous uh
uh theorist on on quantum mech mechy
once said to his students that if you
understand what i'm going to explain to
you then it's because i misspoke
having listened to you just now i wonder
are we actually meant to grasp the
nature of
quantum physics could we just try again
could you sort of
explore again in layman's terms what it
is about
yes yes let us continue
i think as we are continuing to
discussing
things will gradually become clearer now
richard feynman really liked to be
provocative but
for what we have already discussed it is
clear
that quantum mechanics does not obey the
same kind
of logic as the one that is
uh usually used in classical physics and
therefore somebody
who wants to stick with the frame of
thinking
of classical physics will find quantum
mechanics extremely non-intuitive
by the way richard feynman was very
visionary in how we could exploit
the weird property of quantum mechanics
and for example
in a famous talk in 1981 and then in a
paper
he really launched the idea of a quantum
computer which is
one of the most promising technologies
that
are built on this awareness of quantum
mechanics that
is now becoming available so feimein
said
that because the the physics of quantum
system was so different
from that that is predicted by the laws
of classical physics
we should not use classical computer to
try to simulate quantum system but
instead we should use a quantum computer
and this was really the beginning
of the effort to develop this quantum
computers that as i said nowadays
became available another very
visionary statement of richard feitman
that he made much earlier in
1959 is to say there is plenty of room
at the bottom
and by this he meant that we should
exploit
the the discreteness of charge of energy
of small particles that are called
nanoparticles that are aggregates of
atoms and and sometimes molecule to
build new materials to build
new sensors and this was the
the prediction or the preload to the
development
of nanotechnologies but this occurred
much later
in 1990 so
we we have this on the one hand the
discreteness of
energy the wave particle
duality we we have the possibility to
build
material at the nanoscale that now are
available
and all this progress really puts us
in a new regime where we can
start to really exploit the weird
properties
of quantum mechanics
[Music]
you